a new entry has been added to the Oxford
English Dictionary as of today the
phrase no no god I hope not never know
cleanser yes at least it does if you're
the developers of payday 2 who said that
two years ago in response to a question
asking if there would be micro
transactions in the games because now
there are micro transactions in the game
our people little mad about that no no
god I hope not never no I'm Kate and
this is your game spot news update
overkill software has released an update
to the PC version of payday 2 adding
micro transactions for random item drops
the impact gameplay in the team based
multiplayer shooter according to its
developer the black market update is
designed to open up a brand new way of
allowing you to personalize your weapons
with skins mods and more items are
required by unlocking safes which can
only be done by purchasing a special
drill for two dollars fifty once the
safe is cracked open the player is given
a random weapon skin which bestows a new
ability to the gun the developer
explains the process on a bespoke black
market website vlad's operation is
smuggling brand new precision engineers
safes from Washington State to
Washington DC but these safes are tough
to open only the best oysters with the
right tools can crack them each safe
drops a spec weapon skin and each skin
may have special mods and a stat boost
associated with it sometimes very rarely
a safe may even contain a precious
legendary skin much like counterstrike
global Offensive an team fortress 2
these skins can also be sold or traded
on the steam community market
effectively creating an in-game economy
in January 2013 payday 2 lead designer
David Goldfarb said the game would not
have microtransactions cost if the
studio anticipated putting them in the
game Goldfarb said no no god I hope not
never know Goldfarb has since left
overkill saying that his decision to
leave was due to a personal ambition to
leave Triple A game development and not
because of a lack of faith in the
company how do you feel about micro
transactions and games let us know in
the comments below I'm Kate you can
follow me on Twitter at how not to draw
and thanks for watching
you